6 44 it's a friday morning and as you
see there las vegas now host mercedes
martinez helping us rise and shine this
morning with a cornucopia a plethora a
cavalcade of positive stories she's live
in the mix 941 studio this morning hey
mercedes what's going on
hey not much john good morning a lot of
stuff is trending this morning including
ed sheeran ed sheeran has put out new
music and now we know when we can get
our hands on it
[Music]
that's a snippet from his new song bad
habits it is on his equals album which
drops on october 29th now the title is
actually just the equal sign and that
really fits into his pattern of previous
album titles which includes signs for
plus
multiply and divide now next up makeup
that looks so good you are gonna want to
eat it revolution beauty just dropped
this new line inspired by
fruity pebbles and cocoa pebbles cereal
there are lip oils lip glosses brush
kits highlighters and two eyeshadow
palettes products cost between eight and
twenty two dollars now they smell like
the cereals but unfortunately john
they're not edible big huge missed
opportunity there yeah i i've wanted for
years to be able to eat makeup uh but
mercedes if i compliment someone on
their makeup i won't be surprised if
they say actually this is my honey nut
cheerios uh eye shadow
yeah or or this is my uh
raisin bran lip gloss
that'll be a bit confusing all right
let's uh change gears a little bit
mercedes you uh we always talk about
tick tock you've been trying for years
to get me to be on tick tock i'm not on
the tick tock yet but what what is there
right now we should see
well first of all i'm not giving up my
quest to get you on twitter no i know
may i present
may present to you zero gravity woman a
woman filmed her very first time on the
zero gravity ride at pennsylvania's york
state fair take a look
the best part is hearing her say that
trying to make a tick tock over and over
as she is totally freaking out john
try to make it tick-tock her face
oh my goodness
i think what we do
we get you on tick tock john and we put
you up on the big shot on the
stratosphere and then we have you do the
same thing i'm trying to make a tick
tock yeah but i can't compete with that
she is that's next level stuff there i
i'll never be that uh
compelling in my tick tocks my goodness
i hope she survived her tick-tock
experience my goodness
she held over to her phone which is
unbelievable i that is multi-tasking at
its finest so you know how they always
say doing it for the gram that's doing
it for the tick tock that's what that
was right there doing it
all right mercedes have yourself a good
weekend we'll catch up with you next
week take care yourself enjoy the rest
of your program